depuis hier les représentants syndicaux
sont reçus à Matignon une première
depuis la promulgation du texte on sait
pas jeter Nino verre d'eau ni quoi que
ce soit à la figure
c'était une discussion ferme de chaque
côté de la table on nous avait vendu du
dialogue social ouvrez fermer les
guillemets on a assisté à deux heures de
monologue patronales nous n'avons plus
confiance nous avons été trahi d'une
certaine façon à l'occasion de la crise
sur les retraites la première ministre
encore une fois a refusé de retirer la
réforme des retraites au mépris de
toutes les évidences j'ai été très clair
dès le départ on a redit qu'il y avait
un ressentiment et un rejet des 64 ans
visage fermé Nicolas Sarkozy sort de
l'eau Durance il vient d'être condamné
pour corruption active et trafic
d’influence à 3 ans de prison dont un
enferme sous placement d'un bracelet
électronique et trois ans de privation
de ses droits civiques décision là me
semble stupéfiante elle est criticable
contestable endroit en fait et nous ne
lâcherons pas
ce combat là pour la présidente de la
cour d'appel Nicolas Sarkozy avait le
devoir d'être un citoyen respectueux de
la loi or il s'est servi de son ancien
statut de président de la République
pour servir son intérêt personnel ça n'a
pas traîné trois personnes sont en
détention provisoire après l'agression
du petit neveu de Brigitte Macron elle
comparaissait immédiatement comme on dit
arrêtez et placer en garde à vue dès
lundi soir ces deux hommes ont raconté
aux enquêteurs leur version de
l'agression de Jean-Baptiste trogneux
exactement devant la porte des
entrogneux du coup Jean-Baptiste
trogneux est parti
directement il est sorti en fait et il a
plaqué mon camarade et puis mon camarade
c'est pas laissé faire pour légit la
défense ce qui choque le plus c'est leur
profil en fait voilà c'est tous des des
jeunes qui ont un jeune adulte plus une
mineure qui ont un parcours un peu
chaotique un peu cabossé qui ont des
difficultés d'ordre
psychologique pour la plupart moi je
suis arrêté pour rien parce que moi j'ai
rien fait et les histoires parce que moi
je suis décalé
les bagarres en fait on a touché quand
même un symbole de cette famille là et
moi déjà pendant la crise des gilets
jaunes j'étais allé voir la famille trop
mieux le chocolatier pour lui dire que
je lui apporter mon soutien même si
j'apportais mon soutien aussi au gilets
jaunes parce que on défend pas la
démocratie on défend pas la République
en s'en prenant un chocolatier futile de
la famille de Madame trogneux dans un
tweet Jean-Luc Mélenchon condamne et
renvoie la balle je lui exprime ma
compassion et je joins ma protestation à
la sienne je demande à Macron et Madame
d'en faire autant pour nos amis agressés
ou menacés vous dites que c'est la
France insoumise qui instrumentalise la
violence dans le pays
la majorité malheureusement
que créer un climat de tension permanent
dans l'hémicycle et dans le pays mettre
sous tension systématiquement le pays
oui c'est une volonté délibérer la
France insoumise à Matignon c'est
l'épilogue d'une longue séquence celle
d'un maire qui s'estime abandonné par
les services de l'État reçu en début de
soirée par Elisabeth borne on a alerté
la gendarmerie en leur demandant ce
qu'il pouvait faire et là la réponse
était toujours la même toute façon ça ne
sert à rien de déposer plainte nous ne
ferons rien voilà c'est la liberté
d'expression la République la police et
la gendarmerie dans le cas du maire de
Saint-Brevin la gendarmerie a fait son
travail peut-être on aurait dû faire
davantage incontestablement bien sûr que
c'est une remise en cause de l'action
que nous menons à tous collectivement un
courrier au préfet demandant en fait un
soutien de l'État parce que c'est vrai
qu'on se sentait un petit peu au niveau
de la commune de Saint-Brevin démunie le
gouvernement s'engage le ministre de
l'Intérieur les préfets et les forces
les forces de l'ordre sont mobilisées
cour revenu sans réponse quand on vient
aux nouvelles révélations BFM TV
concernant Carlos Martin bilongo une
semaine après l'ouverture d'une enquête
le visant pour fraude fiscale et
blanchiment le député de la France
insoumise est à nouveau dans la
tourmente qui n'agit pas comme un groupe
élu depuis 2022 ça n'est pas vrai c'est
un groupe d'agitateur ils ne sont pas
parlementaires ils utilisent leur
fonction parlementaire pour déployer un
militantisme d'agitation on apprend
qu'il a bénéficié jusqu'en décembre 2022
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à 6 mois après son
élection d'un logement social qu'il sous
louait à l'une de ses sœurs alors même
qu'il était qu'il est propriétaire de
deux autres appartements